we are asked what is 10 to the 5th power
equivalent to well 10 to the 5th power
is the same thing as taking a 1 and
multiplying it by 10 five times let's do
that so that's 3 4 & 5 so it's 1 times
10 times 10 times 10 times 10 times 10
notice 1 2 3 4 5 and what's this going
to be well 1 times 10 is 10 10 times 10
is 100 100 times 10 is 1,000 1000 times
10 is 10,000 10,000 times 10 is 100,000
so this is going to be 100 100,000 now
you might have noticed every time we
multiply it by 10 we're adding another
zero to the product so if we're
multiplying by 10 five times we're going
to add five zeros to the product so this
is good little ego a it's literally
going to be 1 1 followed by followed by
5 zeroes 1 2 3 4 5 so 10 to the 5th is
the same thing as 100,000 let's do
another one that is on a similar topic
how many zeros does the product 67 times
10 to the fifth have well there's a
bunch of ways of thinking about that 67
67 times 10 to the fifth is the exact
same thing this is equivalent to you
could view this as 67 times and we could
use the last exam exact logic that we
just saw in the previous problem so 67
times 1 times 10 times 10 times 10 times
10 times 10 and we already figured out
exactly what this is if you have 1
multiplied by 10 5 times this right over
here is going to be 1 followed by 5
zeroes 1 2 3 4 5 so or it's going to be
a hundred thousand so there's a couple
of ways to think about it if you're
looking at just this product right over
here you could say well 67 times 1 is
just going to be 67 and then every time
you multiply it by 10 you're going to
add another 0 so you could say well this
is just going to be 67 and we're going
to be multiplying by 10
five times so we're going to add five
zeros here one two three four five and
so this would come to six million seven
hundred thousand another way you could
think about it this is the same thing as
sixty seven times 100,000 so it's going
to be sixty seven and then we have five
zeros here so once again one two three
four five you get the exact same value
let's do another one how many zeros is
the quotient five million seven hundred
thousand divided by ten to the third
power half well ten to the third power
we already know two n to the third power
that's the same thing as 1 times 10
times 10 times 10 which is the same
thing as 1000 and so if we're dividing
by that that's the same thing so another
way of writing this expression right
over here so five million seven hundred
thousand divided by divided by 10 to the
third is the same thing is the same
thing as I could write it this way five
million seven hundred thousand divided
by ten times ten times ten
we could put a 1 out here but this won't
really change the value which is
equivalent to five million seven hundred
thousand divided by 1000 and either way
you think about it every time you divide
by ten you're going to eliminate one of
these zeros so if you divide by 10 three
times if you divide by ten once you're
going to eliminate a zero divided by ten
again you're going to eliminate another
zero divided by ten again you're going
to eliminate another zero you're going
to be left with five thousand seven
hundred another way of thinking about it
is well if I'm dividing by something
that has three zeros I'm going to
eliminate three zero so if I eliminate
three zeros I eliminate three zeros I am
left with five thousand seven hundred
now just to be clear I could only do
this because this was one thousand if
this was like three thousand or
something I could I could think of this
as three times a thousand and then I
could only cancel out the one thousand
with these zeros but the three I would
then have to divide separately but only
because I'm straight-up dividing by a
thousand I'm dividing by a power of 10
I have three zeros here I can cancel it
out with three zeros there let's do
another one
there are ask you a few and these are
the type of exact questions that you
might see in the exercise when 72.1 is
multiplied by 10 to the third the
decimal point moves blank places to the
blank and in the exercise you might see
a drop down here so remember if you're
multiplying by a and this is a this is a
essentially 10 to the 3rd you're
multiplying by a thousand you're going
to get a larger number you're not you
know you're not going to get a smaller
number and so every time you multiply by
10 your decimal point is going to move
to the right because you're getting
larger so we're going to move the
decimal point so 72.1 if we multiplied
it by 10 once then we would move the
decimal point over 1 so we get 721 which
makes sense 72 times 10 is 720 72 point
one times 10 should be 721 but if we
want to multiply it by 10 three times
we're going to move the decimal place
over not just once but twice and three
times and you say wait wait how can I
move it over there's nothing here well
you throw a zero in there and so you're
going to get it's going to be equal to
so it's going to be equal to 70 2,100
now they're not asking us that they're
just asking how we would do it and we
saw the decimal point moves three places
to the right and the big key here's
you're going to get a larger number when
you multiply by 10 three times or
multiply by a thousand let's do this one
when 56 is divided by 10 to the third
the decimal point moves blank places to
the blank
well dividing by 10 to the third is the
same thing as dividing by 10 three times
and every time you divide by 10 it's
going to become a smaller number so 56
you might say where is the decimal point
well there's implicitly a decimal point
right over there you divide by 10 1 so
you're going to get a smaller number 56
is going to become 5 in something so
it's going to become literally five
point six divided by 10 again it's going
to become 0.5 6 divided by 10 again
you're like wait if I keep moving the
decimal place again to the left where
where is what am i moving it to the left
off well you can throw a zero right over
here and so if you move the decimal
point three places to the left three
places to the left you are left with
point zero
five six and you might want to put a
zero out here just for for clarity but
what we did here is we moved the decimal
point three places to the left in this
situation we got a smaller value